ANDY NICHOLLS: For
those of you who
don't work in the pharmaceutical
industry, what this--
and indeed, for
those of you who do,
this diagram in front of you
is essentially an org chart
and it's also a timeline.
So this is how the
biostatistics department at GSK
is structured.
I say it's like a timeline
because our structure
essentially reflects the
drug development lifecycle.
So this can take up to 15 years,
which is why this at the bottom
is presenting.
And that takes us to--
so the research in vivo,
in vitro true
analysis all the way
through to the
clinical development.
And by and large, if you're
not from industry, or you are
and that's familiar to
you, you can slice this up
into two distinct ways
of working, really.
The first is the sort
of non-clinical area.
And that's actually where
my group [INAUDIBLE] is set.
This is where research
statistics on our manufacturing
statistics sit as well.
And that's a large group of
statisticians, programmers,
data scientists--
right about 100 people.
But overwhelmingly, the vast
majority of people in our group
sit within the clinical space.
And the clinical space has
very, very different controls
and ways of working to
the non-clinical space.
And it's the clinical
space that we're going
to be talking about today.
So a team of 500 clinical "data
scientists," we can call them.
And I put "data scientists"
in quotes on these slides.
Because really, if you speak
to anyone in that department,
very few people would
actually call themselves
a data scientist.
They are made up
of people whose job
title is either statistician
or programmer generally.
And one of the reasons why
I think that I would also
probably not call them
data scientists in a sense
is that for me, a
data scientist is
someone who is multi-skilled
in a number of different ways.
So they're not simply
a statistician.
They can code a bit as well.
They can use
different languages.
They use the right
tool for the job.
And although there's a
huge amount of talent,
that 500 statisticians
or programmers,
at the start of
our journey, they
weren't really data
scientists in the sense
that I'm describing.
I'm just to give you an
idea of what kinds of skills
we do have, away from just pure
statistics and pure programming
skill.
I put up some rough
estimates of proficiency
within department at the
start of this journey in 2018.
And as you can see,
the overwhelming party
can program in
stats I've said 99%.
I put 100%, but I'm allowing
myself a little bit of room
for one or two people who can't.
But essentially everybody
can program in SAS
There is some proficiency
in R in the clinical space,
but largely R has
been used historically
for the generation of
graphics, and SAS still
dominates in that area.
It's normally bespoke.
Graphics are particularly
difficult to generate in SAS.
But R has been useful along
with a few very proactive R
users pushing off of graphics.
And for clinical
trial simulations
where R arguably lends itself
better towards simulations.
Python again, I'm trying to
cover myself with 1% percent.
Essentially, nobody's using
Python in this clinical space.
But just in case, I put 1%.
And Julia, essentially,
I put up there
to make it sound like I
know what I'm talking about.
Essentially, no one
is using [INAUDIBLE]..
So why are we not using R?
Well, a lot of it comes
down to the past 20 or 30
years of drug development.
And skills have been built
up over that time in SAS.
And alongside those
skills, the tools we use,
what are called SAS macros.
Which, if you're not
familiar with SAS,
would be akin to an R function.
You can think of all the
functions and packages
you might build in R.
All those kind of tools
that we build to make our
job easier are all have all
been built in SAS.
And in a clinical space, it's
very, very heavily regulated.
And so we have systems that
control to a very fine nature
our workflows that we use.
And these systems as well
are entirely built for SAS.
Add all that to the fact
that it's very conservative.
The further along you
get along the pipeline,
the more conservative it
gets within our industry.
And you can start to see
why R hasn't been used.
But the real one--
the one I hear a lot
is this statement here.
The regulators only accepts
[INAUDIBLE] performed in SAS.
This is essentially a
myth that has been around
for a long time.
It gets repeated in
various different forms.
I'll now try to give
you an idea of the one
on the slide as to
what really that means
and where that comes
from-- at least,
where I think it comes from.
So you have, for
example, when you
submit funding for submission
with the FDA, the Food and Drug
Administration America, you
have to provide data sets
and assess transport format.
And that's an open format.
And this statement is--
I put a link in the bottom
as to where that comes from.
This statement here
is from the FDA.
[INAUDIBLE] an open standard.
I put in line a code,
submit a pseudocode
on the right-hand
side to highlight just
how easy that is to
generate in R. In fact,
it's less code in R hat it
would take in SAS ironically.
But these kinds of things,
these kinds of statements
get put out there.
And I think because it has
[INAUDIBLE] there's always
this assumption
SAS has to be used.
What people on very, very
close to the submission end
of things, it's easy to
see how that gets changed
and transformed over time.
And people get very used to
SAS-dominated way of working.
On the regulator note, I
could talk for an entire hour.
I won't be, but I could talk for
an entire hour on this topic.
Phil mentioned that
in the introduction.
If you are interested in
the regulatory barriers
or perceived regulatory
barriers that we
face in the
pharmaceutical space,
I would recommend you
go to www.pharmar.org.
This is the all validation
hub that Phil mentioned.
And you can see
here in particular,
a white paper on risk-based
approach to package validation.
Given all these
barriers and challenges,
why are we looking at R now?
I think one of the key reasons
is the influx of new talent
and skill around R coming
from college, from university.
And we may have people
who have been using SAS
to 20 or 30 years,
but [INAUDIBLE] people
with skills in R,
generally, they're not
coming out with skills in SAS.
And what we're doing is because
no one else understands R
very well, we're
having to retrain them.
All of their education
has been in R.
And we're retraining them
in SAS to make them--
so they can work
with everybody else.
And now, I think it's
probably fair to say
we've reached critical mass.
And we've got so
many people who never
want to use R. We're now looking
at it the other way around.
Let's retrain some of our--
some of the people who've been
there for 20 or 30 years in R.
The other piece is the
drive for innovation.
And that's not new.
We're Always driving
for innovation.
But I think there's a
few things in particular
I've highlighted on this slide.
The last two-- the
communication of visualization
and the productivity
gains I mentioned.
I'll go through a bit more
detail in the next slide.
For now, just to talk about the
methodologies and simulation,
what we're seeing is
an increased drive
to use the latest statistical
methodologies to try and design
more efficient trials.
And when I talk about more
efficient trials, what
I mean is if you think about
a drug getting to market,
up until the point
where you have proved
the efficacy and the
safety of that drug,
your drug is something that you
want to expose as few people
to as possible.
It's a potentially
dangerous compound
that we want to
make sure that we
were minimizing that exposure.
So we need to reduce that.
And equally, if it is
effective, and it's safe,
we want to get it to market
as quickly as possible.
And there's been a
lot of investment
in things like [INAUDIBLE]
GSK and other methodologies
to try and create a
more streamlined process
for developing drugs.
And a lot of that requires
heavy amounts of stimulation.
And there are a
lot of tools that
are built around that
are available in R.
So they're really, really
pushing things forward as well.
Before we move
onto the last two,
I'm going to talk
about visualization
and the dynamic
reporting aspects.
I just want to mention
a couple of others
that often get talked about
in relation to adoption of R.
The first one
being cost, I think
cost is important [INAUDIBLE].
It wouldn't put it as
it as important as any
of the other things on
this slide actually.
When you think about cost, yes,
R is free and tools like SAS
are not.
But there's a huge cost
in training 500 people
and updating all of our
standard tools, and systems,
and so on as well.
So in a sense that
the cost, yes, there's
some long-term cost savings,
but in the short term,
it's probably the
other way around.
And then the last
one, the gateway
to Python and open source--
everything I'm talking about
here with respect to R,
you could switch out
R and put in Python,
or any other open source tool.
R is being more statistical,
I guess, in nature,
at least in its origins compared
to something like Python.
It's a more natural language
in the pharmaceutical space
to use.
And that's why we've
chosen it as the tool
to sit alongside SAS.
But certainly once we've
proved the case for the R,
and if you go back to
that validation point,
you can prove that case
for R. Why not Python?
Why not Julia?
Why not other languages?
[INAUDIBLE] open
source space, you
can start taking advantage of
some of the interoperability
between these tools.
So the two GSK catalysts
I wanted to talk about--
the first one is
the Shiny User Case.
And this is something we call
quantitative decision making
at GSK.
In a nutshell, it
is the probability
of being able to make a
decision at the end of the trial
given the operating
characteristics of the study--
so the study design and various
other pieces of information
that we know up front.
I don't want to talk to
this in a lot of detail.
Again, this is something I
have given a whole presentation
on in the past.
But essentially,
what we try and do
with quantitative
decision making at GSK
is we take known values.
So up in the top
right-hand corner,
there's a diagram here
where it talks about--
this is looking at
treatment difference.
So on the x-axis,
you've got a difference.
For example, the difference
between our drug and placebo,
our drug and some
competitor on the market.
And in a standard
clinical trial,
you might look at the difference
between those two compounds.
And you're going to generate
some kind of p-value.
And if it's a late
phase study, you
might be looking for
something like p less 0.05
to show that there is some
kind of treatment difference.
I'm not as great
at the study level,
but what [INAUDIBLE]
is looking at really
is the lifecycle
of the compound.
So in the early phases of
development, so in phase 2
where [INAUDIBLE] is
particularly used GSK,
you can't [INAUDIBLE] to be able
to make those [INAUDIBLE] kind
of statements.
What you want to be able
to do is given everything
you know about
the drug, you want
to be able to estimate
probabilities.
What's the probability that
the difference between the two
compounds is greater than
some clinically meaningful,
commercially viable difference?
Now, all of this is
quite complicated--
uses a bayesian framework.
We put priors on all
the information we know.
There's a lot of study design
elements that we consider.
And what we're trying
to get to the end
is the probability of
success of the studies.
So the probability
that we're going
to be able to make
a clear decision as
to whether to continue into
the next phase of development
or stop development
of our compound.
Because it's quite complicated.
When we train a lot of our
clinicians in the methodology,
they weren't immediately
receptive to everything
that we were saying.
It's a lot of
complex mathematics.
When mathematics is generally
not their first job.
So we developed an app.
And in doing so,
[INAUDIBLE] all the factors.
Things like the sample size,
the randomization ratios,
standard deviation, things
you can see on the screen here
hopefully, and you combine
that with information
about the minimum value
and the target value,
and potential loss of other
operating characteristics
as well.
And you allow the
clinician teams
to play around with the
sliders in different options.
And then it starts to
become real for them.
They can start to see what
the impacts of study design
is on the ultimate
probability of success.
And that's really led--
because this is such an
important initiative of GSK,
it's rolled out across
all of our studies at GSK.
They're in that
phase of development.
And because of that, we're
seeing widespread adoption
of [INAUDIBLE] methodology.
Everyone is seeing
the Shiny apps,
and there's a huge number of
requests for additional Shiny
apps.
Second example of brief
[INAUDIBLE] a little bit more
briefly.
The-- is dynamic reporting.
Essentially a submission process
at the moment or a development
process is such that we
generate summary data sets
in a very old-fashioned,
boring text tables format
at the moment.
And we generate
these in the same way
we've done for 20 or 30 years.
And that's fine
for R submissions.
But then when we want to
present those in a PowerPoint
presentation, and we want
to publish those results
in some other way, what
we find ourselves doing
is reformatting all
that information.
Even in fact, in the
clinical study report,
we hand over the data to
our medical writing teams.
And they end up doing
things like manually merging
columns and reformatting some of
the data that we've given them.
Before it goes to the
clinical study report.
So you could use-- if you had--
you weren't using
Microsoft products,
something like R Markdown would
be equally suitable for this.
We actually use the Office
package to prove this concept
last year that we could
just take the data sets,
the summary data sets that
we generated by statistics
and automatically place
all of the outputs
into each of these
different formats
without the need
for huge amounts
to transcription QC, which
is what takes place today.
So I'm just going to give
you a bit of an introduction
and a couple of [INAUDIBLE]----
couple of things that
we're looking at that are really
accelerating the adoption of R
within GSK.
What I want to move
on to now is generally
how we're trying to
build this capability.
So we've [INAUDIBLE] so I guess
some of the marketing company
advertising that we've done
internally to promote R
and in building capability,
I put out something here
which will probably horrify
anyone working in change
management but what I'm calling
a simple recipe for building
capability.
Because the components here--
the ingredients, if you like--
and [INAUDIBLE]
not rocket science.
It's more about how you do it.
And that's what we'll talk about
in the rest of this webinar.
So Tito is going to talk
about the environment
that we've built about
warped environment.
And Michael will
talk about the way
that we're promoting
on the job learning
through initiative [INAUDIBLE].
Before I move on
to training I just
want to highlight
as well that given
this is a heavily
regulated industry,
processes and standards
also plays a big part.
We actually have standard
operating procedures
that effectively
reference SAS directly--
not intentionally,
but our workflows
is so built around
the SAS workflow
that certain elements that
don't even make sense for R.
And of course, marketing,
I've mentioned.
So let's move on,
look at training
before I hand over
to Tito to talk you
through the work environment.
What you can see on the slide
now, which is a build slides,
are three prongs of how
we talk about data science
within biostatistics.
And this is largely base
around our traditional roles.
So the top, we talk
about modeling.
And modeling is the
role that traditionally
performed by a statistician
in GSK biostatistics.
And a programmer would
fulfill that sort of wrangling
what was in biostatistics.
The role that my team
fulfills in promoting R
is more of an engineering role.
And engineering can mean
lots of different things
for lots of different people.
What we mean in
this space is things
like building the environments,
building applications, building
all packages so if you like,
the tooling that goes to help
support data science analysis.
And the way we've gone
about training everybody
is to focus on the Tidyverse
and focus on ggplot2.
So, I've written
these two things.
ggplot2 is clearly
part of Tidyverse.
The reason I separated
them out in this diagram
is because they are two
separate face-to-face courses
that we created.
We should now
[INAUDIBLE] courses
for everyone in biostatistics.
[INAUDIBLE] everyone's got
a base level [INAUDIBLE]
before we move on.
We chose Tidyverse, because
of all of the reasons
you'd normally choose
Tidyverse, so things
like the simplicity of the
functions, the consistency,
and so on.
But also, because
if you're trying
to take people who know
SAS and train them in R,
R is a lot more
expansive than SAS.
It's a language.
You have things like
matrices and list and so on
and can get quite
complicated when you get--
when you get into it.
SAS on the other hand is
built around very simple flows
built around data steps--
simple data steps in SAS.
And the way that that works is
very, very similar to the way
that the Tidyverse is built
around data frames or tables
in the Tidyverse vernacular.
So that makes it a
lot easier for someone
coming across from SAS to R
to pick up tables and pick up
that way of working
than it does.
And in particular, the
[INAUDIBLE] and everything
like that is very
familiar to people
coming from a SAS background.
So building up in
the foundations,
and then in each
of the core areas,
we then look to strengthen
core competency.
So we have bespoke training
in various different forms.
I put in the
right-hand side some
of the methods of delivery.
So this will not all be
face-to-face training.
Lots of this is
guidebooks, webinars,
all sorts of different
things that we
do to promote the learning.
And now, we call stats
training using real GSK data.
And programming PROC
plus here represents
sort of more targeted
training and things
like stringr, lubricate-- those
kind of packages, the more
advanced data manipulation.
And then we look at
things like function
writing from an
engineering perspective.
And then when the
value comes in,
it's around these
kinds of things.
So Shiny clearly plays a
big part of our future.
So we've got some
expansive targets
around building
Shiny capability.
Publishing here, I'm using to
refer to things like Officer
as well as our markdown,
bookdown, blockdown--
those kinds of tools as well.
You can see that
through this, we're
building capabilities in each
direction across the group.
In this particular section,
what I'm going to focus on
is the environment
that we've built
to support our
statisticians, programmers,
and data scientists within
biostatistics and increasingly
now, beyond
biostatistics as well.
We call this environment
warp, because it's
part of a wider
initiative called space.
And if you want to make
that into an acronym,
we sometimes talk about the
Working Area for R Programming
.
As has been mentioned
in the introduction,
the majority of our users are
clinical users, statisticians,
and programmers.
And the kind of data they work
with-- clinical trial data--
is relatively small in
the data science space.
So a few hundred
subjects visiting
a clinic a handful of times,
maybe less than 10 times,
generating at most, in
some of our laboratory data
sets, a few megabytes of data.
Certainly, not generally
in the gigabyte terms.
And the kind of analysis
that we're running
are standard
statistical models--
linear models, generalizing
models, mixed models,
[INAUDIBLE],, these
kinds of things.
And when we simulate
that data, what we
have is computationally
demanding simulations
where we fit that model
over and over again.
As opposed to needing to work
with very, very large data
sources, and trying to solve
problems of memory, and so on.
The only exception
to that is that we
are seeing increasing use of
molecular and genomics data
as well.
And that's something that
we'll have to adopt soon,
respond to in the future.
So in terms of what that means,
the environment is a cover.
Well, we need an interactive
environment at its core.
And I'll talk through
each of these components
in the next few
slides separately.
We need a high
performance capability
to support those simulations
that I mentioned.
And with respect to our new
capabilities, our Shiny apps
and our Markdown-based
workflows,
we need an ability to
share that kind of content.
And of course, to
do anything, we
need access to all
of our data sources.
We've provided this through
a centralized environment.
Probably is not a
surprise to anyone
who works in this industry.
But our aim is to get people
off desktops where we can
and provide a level of
consistency, particularly
in the clinical setting.
We need consistency,
traceability,
transparency in what we do.
And we have a large
number of users
that we need to support
when doing this.
We have capacity at the moment
for around about 1,000 data
scientists with 300
concurrent users we estimate.
This diagram is
just to highlight
some of the
technologies that are
included in this environment.
You'll see, as
well as all R, you
see technologies like
Python and Stan mentioned.
Generally, we access
those through R as opposed
to direct access
through their own ID.
So everything is built
around RStudio Server Pro.
And it's very much designed
as an R-based environment.
All of those other
components there are really
just supporting the
use of R. So even
take something like
Git and GitHub,
that's actually maintained
completely separately
but will provide
a connection in R
to allow the code to be stored
or managed through GitHub.
So we've chosen RStudio So
maybe this is an obvious choice
for many people.
But clearly, the RStudio ID
is the standard ID far anyway.
But increasingly, in
the data science space,
I do see a trend towards more
notebook-like environments.
But really, in a clinical
space, that doesn't work.
We work with scripts primarily.
And for those users
coming across from SAS,
all they've ever known
really is scripts.
So first and foremost,
we need an environment
to be able to develop and
execute scripts and RStudio.
Server Pro is really nice
in that it provides-- well,
RStudio--
the RStudio ID generally
provides notebook access
and obviously use of our
mark down if you want it,
and therefore it's
the best of both.
But it also provides the
ability to load balance.
So for us with our
high number of users,
we actually have two
servers with RStudio Server
Pro running, and we--
users will log onto
a single address,
and they'll be
put onto whichever
server has the most capacity.
And this is also
really, really useful
for things like maintenance
to minimize the downtime
that users experience, as well.
There are some challenges with
the interactive environment,
the load balancing with respect
to high performance usage,
but I'll come onto that
after the next slide.
So in this slide, what
I want to talk about
is our means to manage
such an environment.
So for a regulatory
environment, I
suppose at the moment
we are quite open.
So we're not locking
much down for our users.
First and foremost, we need to
get people off laptops with R.
And on a laptop, they're used
to high levels of flexibility.
So we provide a central
installation of R,
and that installation is
updated every six months.
So we have many,
many versions of R,
and all of the recent
versions are exposed to users.
So for every six months over
a period of three years,
you can go back and
select a version of R
that you want to use.
And when we talk
about a version of R,
we don't just mean the core
and recommended packages.
To date, we currently have
around 450 packages centrally
installed in a system
library, as well.
So when a new user
logs onto the system,
they get access to tidyverse
and other popular packages
for our kind of
work immediately.
They don't have to go and
install those packages.
And moreover, because
these are essentially
installed in the system
library, everyone
has the same version of
those packages, which ensures
a degree of stability in usage.
We do allow
flexibility, so users
can install their own
packages, as well,
in their own personal
user library.
We're not restricted
in that at the moment,
but it's very likely that we'll
supplement this environment
in the future with more static,
stable versions of R that
are a bit more locked down.
The only element of
control that we really
have on the environment is
provided through RStudio
Package Manager.
So RStudio Package Manager
provides access to packages
that users would
typically go and install
from CRAN, Bioconductor,
GitHub and so on.
And with respect to
CRAN and Bioconductor,
we pretty much provide
the whole of CRAN
and-- well, we do provide the
whole of CRAN and Bioconductor.
For GitHub, users
would have to request
that particular repositories
are added to our environment
before they can install that.
So they can't directly access
CRAN, Bioconductor, or GitHub,
or anywhere else.
And we also have our
own GitHub enterprise
at GSK, as well, which we
release packages on to,
and users can use
RStudio Package
Manager to access those.
What's actually really, really
nice about our studio package
manager is that it allows
us to monitor the downloads.
And so when we see users
installing-- many users
installing the same
package, what we can then do
is to install that
in the central system
library in a future release.
Again, just to limit the
amount of personalization
and customization that might
affect the transferability
of our code.
And speaking of central
monitoring, another really nice
feature that is the--
that admin support team
use quite extensively
is the admin screens that are
available through R Studio--
through the RStudio Server Pro.
So here you can see
a view of our system.
What I haven't mentioned
thus far is that the system--
these two servers that we
use are very, very powerful
servers.
They're originally intended
for high performance computing,
so they each have 192
cores and 3 terabytes
of RAM, which is why
you can see sort of 1%
CPU memory usage on here.
So generally, we are not pushing
these servers to their limits.
What you can see, though,
are these little spikes that
occur here, and these are--
these spikes occur when a
user tries to paralyze--
or does successfully
paralyze code
and executes that
in the background.
So we can monitor the
system, see these spikes,
and then talk to those users.
Users are permitted
to generate--
they are allowed
to paralyze code,
and they are allowed
to practice HPC runs,
but our expectation
is that they run them
on a separate HPC system,
which I'll talk through next.
So that system is fully
accessible from our R Studio
Server Pro environment.
So we built an add-in
to access Slurm,
which is the tool
that we use the--
for accessing our HPC.
So you can see on here each one
of these is a different server.
So when the users in R Studio
Server Pro access that add in,
that--
the information they
enter there essentially
writes the necessary
script to launch that job
on to two separate HPC nodes.
Again, all of these nodes--
every single one of these
servers in this diagram
has 190 cores and 3 terabytes
of memory, which is far too
much for our management node.
It doesn't need
anything like that.
And no doubt we'll change
that in the future,
but certainly for
the HPC that means
we've got some very
powerful servers available.
One point, though, I
mentioned that we've
built an add-in for this.
We were sort of bleeding
edge when we were doing this,
and the functionality wasn't
readily available in R Studio.
I understand that
it is available now.
You can use launcher
within R Studio
to work with Slurm,
as well as Kubernetes,
but until GSK migrates to
start using Kubernetes,
we are still using own custom
add-in at this moment in time.
So beyond the
obvious, I just want
to now highlight the value add,
I guess, of this environment--
so the new things that we can do
now that we couldn't already do
in our SAS based environments.
And for content sharing--
so for sharing Shiny apps,
or Markdown documents,
Bookdown, Blogdown,
we use RStudio Connect.
We have one server at the
moment running RStudio Connect.
In future, again,
that might be two,
so we might evolve to have
a development and production
server.
But at the moment,
it's all in one,
and it's a pretty liberal model.
So users can publish
anything they like.
So you see a lot of apps--
development apps with the
word test next to them.
Primarily, I'd say
the Shiny apps are--
I mean, the Shiny
apps are a mixed bag.
We get all sorts-- the QDM,
quantity decision making app
that I mentioned earlier.
We get various dashboards
that people have created,
training apps, and so on.
The image in the
left hand side is
taken from a proof
of concept we did
to use Shiny to report
clinical trial data.
So we've got an ongoing
initiative at the moment
where we're looking at replacing
a lot of our standard outputs
with a Shiny app, and there's
a lot of questions that
come with that around
things like data access
and what to do if we find
anything in there when
we're exploring the data.
How do we report that?
And so on.
So there are a lot
of questions in that,
but we're starting to explore
Shiny for that, as well.
Otherwise, we also
use RStudio Connect
for all of our
training material.
So most of those are
produced using Bookdown,
and we host those on Connect.
One particular feature I want to
highlight that isn't mentioned
on this slide, but
it is something
that I'm really,
really thrilled about
is there's a feature in
RStudio Connect that allows you
to publish directly from Git.
So we use Git and
GitHub extensively,
particularly within my team.
And you can point
RStudio Connect directly
at a particular
branch on GitHub.
So for example, we'd
have our production apps
pointing at the
master branch, and we
would have a test
branch where we
would point RStudio
Connect at for more
regular updates and testing.
And that's a really,
really nice feature
that often doesn't get
talked about that I just
wanted to highlight.
Otherwise, I think RStudio
Connect generally works really,
really well for us.
The only bit of
guidance that we often
need to work with our users
on is around data access.
So sometimes people
don't understand
how RStudio Connect runs.
You can basically
configure it to run as you,
as the user that's trying
to access that content,
or you can configure it
to run as a generic user.
And that affects things
like data access.
And so we're often
having to work with users
to explain that.
Equally, you can configure--
you can design an app such
that the data is deployed
as part of the app,
or you can write apps to access
external data sources where
some of what I just mentioned
becomes more of an issue.
But there's lots of
different mechanisms
for controlling
access within Connect,
and that's one of the
key advantages, I think,
that we see over it for Shiny--
we see for it for Shiny
apps-- is making sure
that the right people
see the right content.
Just before we round
off, I just wanted
to mention some of the back end.
So I've mentioned things
like relational databases.
These are ideal for
clinical trial data.
Our clinical trial data is
actually stored on file shares
at the moment, but
in future [INAUDIBLE]
on a relational database
or a graph database.
So we've provided access to a
number of internal file shares,
and we're able to access
relation databases, as well.
And at the bottom of the slide
is mentioned Hadoop clusters.
Outside of our sort
of clinical setting,
there are a number of users
who want to access things
like real world data, electronic
health record databases that
are stored on separate
Hadoop clusters within GSK.
So we provide access to those.
And then the second one
down on the slides--
the objects store that we have.
Again, something
that's perhaps not
talked about too much
these days, but I think
we will see it a little
bit more in the future
is the concept of
an object store--
the data.
And we have some
very large structured
and unstructured
data sources that we
access through object store.
And it's something
that's helped us develop
our first clinical RNA
sequencing pipeline, which
we'll be able to announce later
this year, as well as provide--
as well as providing a means
to enable another pipeline that
allowed us to
analyze COVID-19 data
and respond to a demand from
our clinical operations group
to try and understand what
the impacts of COVID-19
is going to be on clinical
trial recruitment.
So there's been a couple
of really nice use cases
where connecting to object store
has been particularly powerful,
and we're very grateful for the
work that's gone into getting
AWSS3 back onto CRAN.
So I'll just finish with an
overview of the whole system.
I've spoken about each
of these components.
The only one really to highlight
that I haven't mentioned before
is this management in any--
I haven't mentioned in any
detail is this management node.
So this contains our
centralized R distribution.
So whether it's Connect, whether
it's interact environments,
or HPC nodes, all of
these are working off
the same base R
installation which
sits on there, as
well as things like R
Studio Package Manager
then to manage that,
and the Slurm workload manager.
So having this extra node
independent from the rest
is kind of useful.
It's not necessary as such to
have it is a separate node.
And as I mentioned in
the previous slide,
it's a little bit overpowered at
the moment for what we need it
for, but it's a really,
really useful component,
as well as the
load balancing that
takes place everywhere else.
And as mentioned, a
future improvement
will be to balance the content
across the Connect servers,
as well.
So with that, I will round
off and hand over to Michael
to talk about our
on the job learning,
so an initiative called
R4QC in particular.
Thank you very much.
MICHAEL RIMLER: Yeah, my
name's Michael Rimler.
I am in clinical programming
within GSK biostatistics,
and I am here to talk about R
adoption story, or our adoption
story, within
clinical programming
and really in the clinical
reporting process.
The objectives of this project
really are kind of twofold.
At top level, one is
driving capability.
So as Andy mentioned, we have--
a vast majority of our staff are
historically SAS programmers,
but we're moving
into this space where
we want to integrate R into
the clinical reporting process.
And to do that, we
need that capability.
We need people to be
able to program in R.
And although people have
developed their skills over--
their SAS skills over time--
I've been in the industry
for 10, 11 years now,
and virtually everything that
I've learned in terms of SAS
has been on the job, where I
had a challenge that I needed
to figure out how to resolve.
And I asked questions.
I looked things up,
and I figured out--
it wasn't from
sitting in classes,
and taking courses, and working
on problem sets, and things
like that.
And so we want to
be able to-- we
want to be able to
build that capability.
And secondly, we want to
establish an environment.
And by environment,
I don't mean what
Tilo was saying environment,
although that, of course,
is very, very important,
but really making sure
that people have the right
to, the permission to engage
in certain activities in the
clinical reporting process.
We know what the ways of
working are, things like that,
so that someone
comes in, and then
has the tools available to
them to do that, as well.
So someone comes in, and we hire
them in, and apples to apples,
they look the same as the
newly hired SAS programmer,
but they happen to know
R, as Andy mentioned,
that this is where a lot of the
folks coming out of university
are coming in with that they
can be just as productive.
They don't have to go through
additional steps of learning
and additional training so
that they can be productive.
They can be productive
right out of the gate.
Along this process, we've been
asking questions like, well,
why are we doing this?
What's the role of R
versus SAS in our future?
And to Andy's point, that
also brings into account
more open source, but
here we're focusing on R.
So what is the role
of R versus SAS?
Now, my perspective in sort
of leading this project--
and I have the--
I feel like I have the support
of our senior management--
is that it's
integrating R in SAS.
It's not about flipping.
A switch and doing R or SAS.
It's about how do we integrate
this into our processes.
How are we doing this?
What are the elements
that are needed to declare
our teams to be R ready?
And what's next?
So SAS has a certain
amount of capabilities.
Other languages have certain
things that they excel at,
but the fact that we're
trying to integrate R
into our processes--
does that open up
the door for our
department to be delivering
other things to our,
quote unquote, customers
beyond our conventional
data sets, tables, listings,
and figures?
This started with
a project that was
called R4QC, where
we wanted to look
at using R for the QC process.
So for those that are unfamiliar
with a somewhat conventional QC
process within
clinical reporting,
you have a production
side programmer
who creates the output.
They create the data set.
They create the table,
that sort of thing.
And then someone else,
an independent programmer
independently creates code
using the same inputs, but then
a different process, because
independently generated.
And if they get the
same outcome at the end,
then that satisfies
a significant level
of the requirements from
a validation perspective.
And so that's what
we were looking
at when the R4QC project.
In parts one and two, we focused
on displays, just looking at--
not looking at data sets.
And it was more of a
proof of feasibility,
proof of concept type model.
We only did about nine
displays in part one,
and then we expanded
the team, and expanded,
and actually, in part two,
we were able to replicate
or doubly validate and
compare to the production side
SAS generated displays
using R, as opposed to SAS.
It was about 150-some
displays that
were in that proof of concept.
That opened the door
for our part three,
where we sort of
go live, which was
one of our initial
objectives, which
is how do we open the
door for all of our staff
to be able to use R, as
opposed to SAS, for something?
Because that allows them to take
any training that Andy's group
is providing and
use it on the job
so that they can
immediately go out and do
their normal everyday
work, but start
to do it in the
language of R, as
opposed to the language of SAS.
And so we had a
number of components,
which I'll go through,
that, in order
to get endorsement for
being able to do that,
but we are now--
our part three has now been
ongoing for about four or five
months now, and we continue
to bring more and more people
into the fold.
At the same time, or roughly
around the same time,
we launched into
part four, which
is a proof of
concept that moves us
into the data sets and
[INAUDIBLE] data set mapping.
These two projects
now have become
under the umbrella of a sort
of new and broader initiative
within clinical
programming on R adoption,
and there I was sort
of tasked with what's
the roadmap to R then look
like for clinical programming?
What is it-- what do we need
to do to get to the point
where we are using R as much
as we are SAS, or at least
they're sort of
interchangeable, or we
have a strategic direction?
That sort of thing.
And before I could figure out a
roadmap, which is when are you
going to do things?
I needed to know what
we're going to do.
What are the thing--
what are the components
of broad adoption of R
within the department?
And that created these
sort of six or seven work
streams, which included
the R4QC remaining
elements of part
three and part four,
but looked at things
like central tools.
So in the SAS world, in
the SAS workflow, we have--
many organizations do.
We have our SAS macro library
suite that people use.
We don't have the same thing in
R. There's packages out there.
Those packages are not written
for the clinical data pipeline,
but they are-- they
do have functionality.
So what can we do to make the
ability for uptake of our SAS
programmers moving
into R easier?
Because we're not asking them
to program for first principles.
We give them a set of tools
that allows them to do that.
And Andy's group on
that engineering side
that he was talking about--
Andy's group provided
those initial packages
that we've been using
through the R4QC project.
There's also a work stream on,
of course, training and support
for our staff.
It's a massive
organization, and this
is a big change in terms
of the way we do our work.
So there's a change management
and a communications piece
to this.
There's outreach.
That's outreach--
we're really driving
this within the clinical
program department,
but there's outreach outside
of clinical programming still
within biostats and
still within GSK,
but also external outreach-- for
example, this type of platform,
where we're sharing our
knowledge and our experience.
We're not the first
ones to go through this,
but we are carving
our own path, and we
do have different experiences.
And the more that we
share, the more that we
can pull the rest of the
industry along with us,
along with the folks
like Genentech,
and Roche, and
the likes of that.
And then, of course, we always
are thinking about, well,
we're doing this on
the QC side of things.
What does it mean to
get R onto production?
Some of that falls
within Andy's group.
Some of that falls within the
tech group, and some of that
falls within the work
that we're doing.
And there's always
the question out there
about submission with R
generated analysis and data.
So that R4QC project--
I talked about it a
little bit already,
and Andy's also
mentioned some of this
also, but why do we decide
to use R in the R4QC project?
We have this long term objective
within clinical programming
to become programmatically
multilingual.
It's not driven by
SAS license costs.
Andy already mentioned
the idea of recruitment.
I also think that
flips to retention
for the folks that have
been within our group
for a long time.
This offers new
and exciting things
that can do-- if you have
interest in doing that.
But operationally,
it also gives us
flexibility, the ability
to choose the right tool
for the job at hand, and also
an expansion of the things
that we might deliver to
our internal customers.
Why did we look at QC?
It's a lower risk
of entry point.
That's what we thought
from the beginning,
that QC programming tends to
have lower regulatory scrutiny.
It's not typically
submitted along
with a submission package.
So therefore, you can have it--
you can have QC code developed
during the reporting workflow,
and in R, as opposed
to SAS, and it's not
going to be challenged as much.
And we're still
producing everything
using SAS at the moment.
So we're taking things that
are produced in a language
and in a workflow that has
been commonly accepted,
and we're simply using
our validation processes
using R. And as
mentioned, that's
going to facilitate the sort of
on the job organic upscaling,
because we know that,
if I need to validate
a summary of
demographics, I can go,
and I can use R within
our RStudio environment
and do that work there, as
opposed to launching up SAS.
Those first few parts, parts
one and two on displays,
and now moving into part
four, all proof of concepts--
we're really thinking about
demonstrating the capability
of using R for stage 2 QC.
In GSK, that's what we refer to
as independent validation-- is
stage 2 QC, and back to that
facilitating the on the job
use of R for upscaling.
We had a number of
successes with that.
We had to figure out how to
actually compare data frames.
We can use PROC COMPARE in SAS,
but how do you do that in R?
Well, there's a
couple of packages
that we identified that
could satisfy this,
and we landed on
the diffdf package.
And that has been
proven successful
through our experience so
far to leverage that package.
We have successful
cross-functional collaboration,
most specifically
with Andy's group,
but that was needed,
because we didn't
have the sort of
internal skillset
that we needed and knowledge.
So we needed to work
cross-functionally.
I mentioned the central tools.
It also gave us a better vision
of our roadmap towards R,
and we developed a
significant amount
of supporting documentation
to help our staff.
Challenges that we faced
and, I would argue, met.
One is onboarding
into the-- what
I would call the R ecosystem.
So that's the work environment
that's working with Git
and GitHub, that's
thinking about having to--
as a programmer, having
to worry about loading
packages, and installing
packages, and things like that.
It's just different
than SAS, and so how
do you take folks that have
been using SAS for 3, 5, 10, 15,
20 years, and say, well, now
we want you to do this in R.
How do you help lower the entry
cost for that so that uptake
can be higher, adoption
can be stronger?
PROC COMPARE and
diffdf-- diffdf seems
to be developed
and designed to be
very similar to PROC COMPARE,
but it has a different look.
It has a different feel.
And so we had to work through
those challenges of how you use
it as a diagnostic tool, not
just an everything compare
sort of result. Good program
practice in R is different.
Also try to institute
some sort of code
review culture, which is--
I don't know what it's
like in every organization,
but it's not as strong as
we would like within GSK.
I think within
clinical reporting--
I think that's primarily driven
by the independence of QC
culture, but trying to build
up a code review mentality
and good program practice.
And we also notice--
because we're comparing SAS
to R results, we also
notice that there
are differences between SAS and
R in some fundamental things.
Not that either
is right or wrong.
When we noticed the differences
in the compare output,
and we dug into it, we realized
that SAS was doing what
SAS said they should be doing.
And R was doing what R
said they should be doing,
and so how do we reconcile that
from a reporting standpoint,
from an analysis standpoint?
If our general concept is, well,
things should match exactly,
and we're not getting
things matching exactly,
how do we sift through that?
More importantly, how
do we support our teams
in navigating that?
When you open the door to let
loose 250 programmers, 350
programmers to do this, they
need to know, all right,
I now see this difference.
What do I do about
this difference?
So we started working
through those sorts of things
with the SAS versus
R differences
that we were encountering.
That brought us to part three.
Part three is
where we go to live
stage two or independent
QC using R instead of SAS.
You could think of running it
as like a pilot study, where
you have a study that says
we're going to just validate
everything using R.
Instead of that model,
we chose to have an organic sort
of grassroots effort to doing
this.
So any individual programmer
at the output level
can say, all right, I've been
assigned 25 different displays,
so I'm going to
choose these three,
and I'm going to validate
these using R instead of SAS.
That's the opportunity to use--
to on the job learn
R and take what
you've learned from the training
coming out of Andy's group,
and use it for the work
that you typically do.
Part of the requirements
of that were making sure
that, of course, the
leadership on the study
was aware of what was happening,
because it doesn't put us--
we don't think it puts a
significant amount of risk,
but it's something from a
resourcing and timelines
perspective leadership
needs to know about.
We have mechanisms in place
to help with ways of working
and also provide visibility
on what's happening,
but really it's-- it was
putting in place a model
of encouragement from above.
So we had leadership in the
team saying, you can do this.
We allow you to do this.
We know it's going to take you
a little bit longer than you
might feel to do it in SAS,
because you're so fluent in SAS
and just learning
R. But we're going
to provide all the support
from below in terms
of documentation,
and the support team
to answer your questions,
and things like that.
On the right here, I'm not
going to go through them.
It's just we outlined a
number of required components
before we would say
it's a green light.
People can go out,
and do this, and use
R. It is a regulated
environment,
so we have to be
conservative in this approach
while we, as well as the
rest of the industry,
is navigating towards the
ultimate objective of sort
of freely being able to
submit packages produced
and using R, and perhaps
other open source languages.
Some of the support
mechanisms we have in place--
I'll run through this
quickly, because I
know that we're running a
little bit short on time.
We put together a
quick start guide
to just be a one stop
shop that links out
to a number of
internal documentation.
And we put together--
on the left here is
a guidance document
that's pretty thorough.
It goes through not just
how to get started, but also
what does it mean to
develop code in RStudio?
How do you execute code?
Some mini vignettes
of going through some
of our standard
display templates,
standard summary of AE template
that's very GSK specific.
But it gives people
sample code, gives things
that they can copy, and
paste, and slightly tweak.
When I was learning
SAS along the way,
I learned by someone
pointing me to a similar type
output in a different study,
and I would copy that code in.
And I would start to
manipulate it to make sure
that it worked for my purposes.
And so I wasn't starting from a
blank sheet of paper every time
I started code.
So that's what we wanted to do.
This document on the left, which
is using the Bookdown package,
was--
it was completely designed
to try and again lower
that transition cost of
someone moving from SAS into R
in order to improve uptake
and improve adoption.
On the right here
is a workplace page.
When GSK uses workplace,
it's a workplace page
that we created also
to support staff
in asking questions,
and communicating out,
and that sort of thing.
So one of the interesting
characteristics of this
is, as we released
this documentation,
we also got some notice
that there's more
that R can do than just our
statistical analysis type work
that you can publish to
this sort of documentation
to RStudio Connect.
That's just another reason to
integrate R into the workflows
that we have.
So we move into the
R adoption journey.
Motivations behind this--
to have this expanded tool
set, to expand our delivery
capabilities, upscaling things
that we've sort of
already talked about.
But we do want to become
amongst those industry leaders,
and not be a follower.
That's where I think
Andy's group wants
to position ourselves.
That's where we want to
position ourselves, as well.
That's why we have this
sort of outreach stream,
that sort of thing.
Coming out of that
project, deliverables.
We want R-ready study teams
for our conventional delivery.
We want an R package
development team for--
to enhance our process--
for process improvement.
We want to have shiny
development teams
for future delivery products.
And, of course, to have a
robust support strategy.
And again, we
always have this eye
on how do we get to
R for submission.
So going back to the
sort of six or seven work
streams here in the R adoption
project, the real question
we have is, how do
you manage change
within a massive organization
without disrupting
that delivery capability?
And in order to do
that, we need to have
a multifaceted approach.
That's where these
work streams came from.
To have focused efforts
within the work stream,
we had leads in place
for each of these work
streams that both define the
objectives and the strategy
towards delivering
to those objectives,
but those efforts are also
integrated and coordinated
because this team
works together.
And the people that are
on each individual team
and leading those teams
are trying to coordinate
and with the ultimate objective
of serving the R adoption
objectives.
So in the last minute and
a half or two minutes,
I just want to do a
little bit of a deep dive
into the essential tools
that some of the packages
that Andy's team
has created for--
to serve our teams in the
clinical reporting process.
So we have two
RStudio add-ins first.
We have a GSK header add-in
and a GSK log add in.
The GSK header just inserts--
it's through RStudio.
It's an interactive way
of inserting and updating
the header in our R programs.
GSK log generates an
execution session log.
There's another add-in, which
is the fourth bullet, called
copy4qc.
This is an add-in
that was generated--
since we're developing
in the warp environment,
but we need the code--
the QC code to be
in our study area
so it can be archived
with the study,
we have to be able
to get it from one
system to the other while
maintaining last modified
dates, while maintaining
the appropriate permissions
for the systems
that they live in.
But we also need 350
programmers to be
able to do this in a
very consistent manner.
And so the best
way to do that is
to provide them a tool
where they hit buttons,
and they have less
and less control--
limited control over
how that's happening,
so we can control that process.
And then we have
two building blocks
of actually doing the work.
So GSK table building blocks
with basic summary displays,
and GSK data set building blocks
of updated set transformations.
I want to focus a little
bit on the GSK log,
and that'll close me out,
because this is something
that we realized early on
was a unique thing here,
because SAS naturally
generates an execution log.
R does not do that.
SAS hits an error,
it keeps going.
R hits an error, it stops.
But people are used
to seeing logs,
and there's a usefulness of
having some sort of execution
log, because it generates a
record of information that's
related to that execution.
So it gets us towards that sort
of GxP compliance requirements
that we have.
The rationale-- again,
R doesn't actually
generate this
information, so we want
to be able to provide
minimum information
to demonstrate the
integrity of that execution,
and details to facilitate
reproduction so
that, if two years
from now someone
were to go back, and
look at the program,
and want to show
reproducibility,
they could recover what
the R environment looked
like at the time, and should
be able to reproduce it.
Maybe not with the
click of a button,
but with a little
bit of effort, you'd
have the information to
reset that environment.
And this is a
challenge or a problem
that's specific to the
clinical reporting workflow.
What Andy's group came up
with that we helped advise on
was not intended to
replicate that SAS log.
The design was as
an RStudio add-in.
We have elements of
who, what, and when.
So who ran the file?
What was the file?
When did it start?
When did it stop?
We wanted to drop in any
sort of errors and warnings.
So in this case,
here's a warning
that the diffdf doesn't have
all values compared equal,
so you can see that.
Information about the R
session and information
about the packages and
versions available.
We took the path of
least resistance,
so it's really all
the packages that
are installed in that
RStudio instance,
not just the packages
that were used
for the production
of that program.
But we do have a sort of
mini backlog of enhancements
that we want to make
to this package,
including moving away from
being an add-in and more
of batch execution
type implementation.